nunca está de más hacer problemas
relacionados con la distribución normal
pues en realidad es un fundamento
esencial para el trabajo estadístico y
de hecho para la vida cotidiana así que
lo que he hecho es tomar algunos
problemas muestra este lo he sacado del
libro de ceca 12 puntos org el cual es
el libro de estadística de arte y es de
libre distribución extraído los
problemas del capítulo destrucción
normal así es que puedes ir al sitio y
de hecho ver estos problemas el primer
problema cuál de los siguientes
conjuntos de datos es más factible que
se distribuya normalmente para las otras
opciones explica por qué crees que nos
seguirían una distribución normal esta
es en realidad más una pregunta de
percepción es poco común en el contexto
de las matemáticas es más una pregunta
acerca de lo que piensas una pregunta
tipo ensayo veamos a la amplitud de la
mano medida desde la punta del pulgar
hasta la punta del meñique extendido
creo saber a qué se refieren voy a hacer
una mano por aquí aquí tenemos el pulgar
luego el índice luego el dedo medio
luego el anular y aquí tenemos el
meñique y la distancia que no están
es la que va de la punta del pulgar a la
punta del dedo meñique o el dedo
chiquito como a veces le dice y esta de
aquí es la distancia a la que se refiere
y establecen que las medidas hicieron a
partir de una muestra aleatoria de
estudiantes de preparatoria cómo se
vería esto qué tan grande sería esto es
una combinación de factores genéticos y
ambientales quizá de cuánta leche
tomaste o qué tanto te colgaban de las
barras agarrados del meñique a medida
que iba creciendo me parece que esto es
debido a la combinación de una gran
cantidad de procesos aleatorios en fin
yo sí esperaría que esto se destruyera
aproximadamente normal o no sé si veo mi
propia mano no creo que haya crecido
mucho desde que yo estudiaba la
preparatoria estimo que debe medir 9
pulgadas ahora yo tocaba la guitarra
quizás esto propició que mi mano se
estirará pero como te decía es una
pregunta tipo ensayo es algo que tengo
la sensación que es así es que me parece
que la distribución se vería como esto
no sé en un que he hecho esto quizás la
media estaría en 8 pulgadas o 9 pulgadas
y la forma de distribución sería algo
así
un poco así se la forma de distribución
quizás se ve como una distribución
normal no perfecta de hecho puedo
garantizar que no va a ser una
distribución normal perfecta pues por un
lado nadie puede tener una longitud
negativa en esa amplitud esta distancia
nunca puede ser negativa podrías decir
que no tienes mano y eso podría ser el
contado como cero pero la distribución
nunca va a tener un dominio negativo así
que no sería una distribución normal
perfecta por el lado izquierdo ésta
tendría como límite el 0 y por el lado
derecho tenemos restricciones físicas
imposibles de superar nadie puede tener
una mano que tenga una amplitud del
tamaño de la atmósfera terrestre o que
estuviera en unidades astronómicas para
que pudiera ser montado tocar el sol hay
un punto a partir del cual es
físicamente imposible y como bien
sabemos en una distribución normal
auténtica si yo he hecho una gran
cantidad de volados hay una probabilidad
muy muy pequeña de que obtenga un millón
de águilas seguidas es casi cero en el
caso de la amplitud de mano la
probabilidad de que un ser humano que
además resulta ser un estudio
preparatoria tengo una amplitud de mano
de no sé digamos una milla de longitud
eso es cero por tanto no va a ser una
distribución normal perfecta sobre todo
para valores extremos que se alejan de
la media pero yo creo que para un
problema de la vida real la aproximación
a una distribución normal va a ser una
muy buena aproximación de la
distribución que vemos aquí creo que
algo interesante aquí esto es para
alumnos varones esto que acabo de hacer
fue desde mi punto de vista como hombre
y podría argumentarse que los
estudiantes varones muy probablemente
tienen manos más grandes que las mujeres
por lo cual es posible que tengamos de
hecho una distribución bimodal por lo
que en vez de tener este tipo de
instrucción tendríamos algo así aquí
tendríamos un pico para los hombres
quizás a 8 pulgadas y luego un poquito
menor un pico para las mujeres a 7
pulgadas y luego la distribución caería
más o menos así así que también es
posible que fuera bimodal pero en
general una distribución normal va a ser
una muy buena aproximación para el
inciso a del problema
veamos ahora que nos piden en el inciso
b los salarios anuales de todos los
empleados de una gran empresa naviera si
estamos considerando salarios anuales
por supuesto que tenemos leyes sobre el
salario mínimo
me imagino que cualquier empresa con
trabajadores de tiempo completo va a
haber un salario mínimo para los
trabajadores de hecho yo diría que
bastante gente tendría ese salario
mínimo serían aquellos que realizan
esencialmente labores manuales entonces
tendrías a la mayoría de la gente en
esta parte baja de la escala de salarios
luego tendríamos los mandos medios
distintos niveles de gerentes y así
luego probablemente tendríamos un gran
hueco hasta llegar a los probablemente
tendríamos a los grandes ejecutivos de
la empresa al director general y ese
tipo de mandos
si la media aquí es pongamos 40 mil
dólares al año y aquí probablemente
80.000 donde probablemente se encuentra
el nivel de salario de los mandos medios
y por acá más arriba esto probablemente
será si tomamos la misma escala que he
usado esto sería 80 160 quizás 200.000
que es de hecho un salario razonable
para un alto ejecutivo
en realidad actualmente este tipo de
salarios puede estar realmente arriba
quizás hasta fuera de la gráfica no sé
digamos el director general que gana 5
millones de dólares al año por los bonos
prestaciones estaría hasta acá quizás
con un par de gente más como los
accionistas y ese tipo de directivos mi
opinión es que definitivamente no es una
distribución normal tienes un segundo
pico tienes una distribución bimodal con
los salarios de los altos ejecutivos por
acá a menos de que bueno no no lo están
diciendo pero si estuviéramos en europa
esto estaría más cercano hacia la
izquierda pero no sería una distribución
normal perfecta y no vas a tener valores
debajo de cierto límite el que hemos
denominado el salario mínimo esto se
llama cuando tienes una cola que va más
hacia la derecha que a la izquierda se
llama distribución sesgada a la derecha
distribución sesgada
a la derecha
tenemos dos picos uno aquí y otro por
acá podríamos decir que es una
distribución modal esto depende del tipo
de compañía pero bueno esta sería mi
opinión para los salarios de una gran
empresa nadie la veamos el inciso c o la
parte c del problema los salarios
anuales de una muestra aleatoria de 50
directores de las principales compañías
25 mujeres y 25 hombres el hecho que
hayan estipulado esto yo pienso que es
quizás debido a que la brecha entre
salarios por género no se ha cerrado
implicando que diferencias entre hombres
y mujeres si fuera simplemente 50
directivos de principales compañías yo
diría que se acerca muchísimo una
distribución normal sería algo así de
nueva cuenta a haber un salario límite
inferior debajo del cual ningún
directivo estaría dispuesto a trabajar
aunque yo he escuchado de algunas
personas que llegan a trabajar gratis
claro que les pagan de otra manera si tú
incluyes todos estos casos tendríamos un
salario base para la mayoría de los
directores de aquí subiría la
distribución hasta un valor el valor más
probable y luego seguiría una cola hacia
la derecha y es el caso donde no hubiera
una
de género esta sería una distribución
sesgada a la derecha pura con una gran
cola hacia la derecha ahora suponiendo
una brecha de género aquí tendríamos dos
picos esto sería una distribución
bimodal entonces suponiendo una brecha
de género y estamos haciendo el inciso c
aquí tendríamos un pico para las mujeres
suponiendo que ellas ganan menos que los
hombres otro pico para los hombres de la
misma altura son la misma cantidad de
hombres y mujeres y luego terminaría
sesgando se hacia la derecha de hecho es
muy factible que tuvieras otro pico como
el que encontramos acá donde tienes dos
súper directores que ganan varios
millones de dólares mientras que aquí
tienes a la gran mayoría de los
directores que ganan nada más entre
comillas algunos cientos de miles de
dólares mientras hay un pequeño
subconjunto haya alejado muchas
desviaciones estándar a la derecha así
que inclusive podríamos tener una
distribución trimodal aquí este fue el
inciso c hasta ahorita el inciso a es el
mejor candidato por una distribución
normal pura o por lo menos el que más se
acerca a eso veamos el inciso d
las fechas de 100 peniques tomados de
una caja registradora en una tienda de
conveniencia 100 peniques es un
experimento interesante mi opinión sería
y de nueva cuenta es una pregunta donde
expresa su sentir acerca de estas cosas
es decir mientras tu respuesta sea
razonable yo diría que es correcta la
mayoría los peniques son nuevos porque
salen de circulación se intercambian se
gastan se pierden a veces inclusive los
presionan para usarlos como souvenir en
las tiendas de turismo yo no sé si
legalmente se puede hacer eso con el
dinero mi opinión entonces es que si
fuera graficarlo vas a tener toneladas
de peniques dentro de un lapso de un par
de años pero nos están preguntando las
fechas no la antigüedad las fechas
entonces si aquí tenemos el 2010 y
seguro no vas a encontrar ahorita del
2010 pero vas a encontrar toneladas de
peniques de 2009 y de ahí va a bajar
pero por supuesto no vas a encontrar
peniques que sean más viejos digamos de
los eeuu o de que se empezaron a acuñar
peniques por lo que obviamente esta cola
no se extiende
a la izquierda indefinidamente así que
mi opinión en este caso es que tú tienes
una distribución sesgada a la izquierda
sesgada a la izquierda con la mayoría de
los datos hacia el lado derecho y una
cola que va hacia la izquierda por eso
se llama distribución sesgada hacia la
izquierda y en ocasiones distribución
sesgada negativamente sesgada
negativamente así como una distribución
sesgada a la derecha también se le
conoce por distribución sesgada
positivamente y si solo tienes un pico
no tienes una distribución multimodal
como esta en una distribución sesgada
hacia la izquierda la media va a estar a
la izquierda de la mediana así en este
caso la mediana quizás estaría por esta
zona y tu media dado que hay una gran
cola hacia el lado izquierdo estaría por
aquí de manera similar en esta
distribución tu mediana el valor medio
estaría en algún lugar por aquí y tu
media estaría a la derecha dado que hay
un solo pico aunque que otro pico pero
ese no cuenta mucho entonces tu media
estaría por aquí ese es otro motivo por
la cual se llama distribución sesgada a
la derecha o distribución sesgada
positivamente así que respondiendo la
pregunta
estas son mis opiniones acerca de todas
ellas así que yo diría para las altas
opciones porque crees o más bien cuál de
los siguientes conjuntos de datos es más
factible que se distribuya normalmente
yo elegiría la opción a pero ya vimos
que es una cuestión de opinión por lo
menos para esta pregunta